all right you ready for some questions
lady for some questions okay
Deb pallet gasp Lin says I love your tie
where do you get your ties they're
supplied to me by my costume designer
wardrobe guy Bruce Bromwich perfect
TJ Steinberg says what site is Andy's
life [ __ ] Andy can't afford a live blog
he owns that his computer steam-powered
it was designed in 1988 Micro noses are
Lydon's whatever made in the u.s.
they're called they're made on the Isle
which is offs in Asia
Cody Tiger cases what is your favorite
kind of cookie
I like Toll House cookies with aspirin
in them you get the chocolate and then
you just feel good because of the
aspirin Gloria Thompson says hello I was
wondering how's Jordan he's awesome
Jordan is fine and he's not awesome not
as creepy and mad Enoch says can you
please bring the beard back yeah the
beard may come back at any time you'll
have about nine months of warning
because that's how long it takes the
male loses testosterone every year and I
basically have very at the same
testosterone level now as Ruth Bader
Ginsburg
[Laughter]